APRIL ELEVENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING.
NOTING THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
ARE GONNA GO AHEAD AND START AS
A SUB COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK
MISTER GRAY FOR.
SHOWING UP RIGHT NEARLY IN
BEFORE ANY OF US GOODNESS HERE
ON TIME. I DO WANNA KNOW TO THE
MEMBERS COMMITTEE THIS CAN BE
VERY SHORT MEETINGS HAVE YOUR
STAFF ARE WATCHING. IF YOU CAN
GET HERE IN THE NEXT FIVE TO TEN
MINUTES THAT'S ABOUT HOW LONG
THIS MEETING SHOULD LAST AS LONG
AS WE CAN GET QUORUM.
SO WITHOUT MISTER GRAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION AS AMENDED TO
MAKE A TECHNICAL CLARIFICATION
ADDING A FIVE YEAR SUNSET DATE
REQUIRING.
RIGHT.
REQUIRED A FIVE YEAR SUNSET DATE
REQUIRED EVALUATION OF REDUCED
FEES ON HUNTING PARTICIPATION
RATES ESTABLISHES A TWENTY
DOLLAR PREMISE TACKY FOR
ANTELOPE ELK. BEAR IN BE CORN
SHE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE THIS
MORNING.
ON LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING THAT
DODD LIKE EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES
SUGGEST AMENDMENTS. CREATING A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET REQUIRING THE
PART OF FISH AND WILDLIFE TO
REPORT BACK. ON THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS MEASURE.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE IS A
MODEST BUT IMPORTANT BILL TO
ADDRESS THE DRAMATIC DECLINE IN
THE NUMBER OF OUTDOOR SPORTSMAN
AND WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA. OVER
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS.
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IS IN LARGE PART DEPENDENT. ON
THE REVENUES GENERATED BY
OUTDOOR SPORTING ACTIVITIES
THE FUN VITAL CONSERVATION AND
SPECIES MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES.
THESE HUNTING ACTIVITIES DECLINE
MEMBERS.
WELL OVER FIFTY PERCENT.
IN THE PAST DECADES.
THE BILL DESIGNED TO MAKE
HUNTING MORE AFFORDABLE FOR USED
TO ENCOURAGE PROTECT
PARTICIPATION AMONGST THE NEXT
GENERATION OF HUNTERS.
TO PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE.
.
IN CALIFORNIA JUNIOR HUNTERS PAY
FOR HER AND FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
NOT TACK.
YOUTH HUNTERS IN MONTANA
COLORADO PAY TEN DOLLARS AND
SEVENTY FIVE CENTS.
IT IS A DRAMATIC DIFFERENCE IN
ITS PROHIBITIVE.
FOR YOU. NOT TO GET INVOLVED IN
THE SPORT AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
ONE ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THIS
DIVIDE BY GIVING JUNIOR HUNTERS
ACCESS TO LOWER COVER TAGS FOR
ANTELOPE ELK BEAR AND BIG HORN
RAM.
AB TWENTY ONE THAT.
FIFTY ONE A SUPPORT BY THE
CALIFORNIA HUNTING CONSERVATION
COALITION THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF OPERATING ENGINEERS THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WILDLIFE
FEDERATION'S AMONGST OTHERS. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY.
THINK YOU I'M ARE THERE SPEAKERS
INSIDE OUT BEFORE WE START LET
ME GO AHEAD AND STEPS CLIMB.
AND SECRETARY.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
PRESIDENT BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH. CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CHAO.
EGGMAN.
FONG. FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
HIS AREA.
KILEY.
QUIRK HERE REDUCE.
THE BILL.
SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER BELOW
IS TAKEN BY MISTER QUIRK.
I DO HAVE WITNESSES WOULD
SUPPORT HAVE WITH ME A COUPLE
FOLKS IN SUPPORT TODAY.
WE PROCEED
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRMAN ROY GRIP THE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA HUNTERS
CONSERVATION COALITION FIRST I
REALLY WANT THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND GET TO THE POINT
THAT WERE AT.
WE ARE THE NUMBERS OF ALL THE
TESTIMONY AT A VERY LOW COST THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE CAN DO A
VERY GOOD THING AND MAKE HUNTING
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS YOU.
THIS IS A PERSONAL MATTER TO ME
BECAUSE FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS MY CAREER THE DEPARTMENT
FISH AND WILDLIFE ID HERE FIRST
AND. THE CLINK NO COMMENTS AND
COMPLAINTS FROM FAMILIES THAT
COULD NOT AFFORD THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
AFFORD A FIFTY DOLLAR TAG AS
MENTIONS A LOT OF MONEY FOR SOME
SINGLE INCOME FAMILIES REDUCING
THIS TO TWENTY DOLLARS TO MAKE
IT MORE FOR OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND PROVIDE US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WE NEED TO RECRUIT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF OF HUNTERS WHICH
AS WE ALL KNOW. PAY THE COST OF
CONSERVATION CALIFORNIA BRING IN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EACH YEAR
AND IT'S CRITICAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT
EFFORTS TO HAVE HUNTERS IN THAT
MIX.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
SPECULAR QUESTION RIVALS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL.
PORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SOME NON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OKAY THANK.
THANK YOU.
A GRISLY DEPARTMENT FINANCE OF
FINANCE OPPOSES THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT IS INCONSISTENT WITH
THE ANNUAL ADJUSTMENTS GAME
TECHIES FOR INDIVIDUALS EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND OLDER.
AND THE THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES AN
INCREASE OF THIRTY ONE MILLION
FOR ACTIVITIES THAT INCLUDE
PROGRAMS FOR HUNTER RECRUITMENT.
RETENTION AND REACTIVATION
INCREASED HUNTING OPPORTUNITIES
INCLUDING ON LAND UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT'S JURISDICTION.
OF FURTHER IN THE FALL SEVENTEEN
THE DEPARTMENT CONVENED A BROAD
COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS. OF
ONE OF THE TOPICS DISCUSSED FOR
SOLUTIONS TO INCREASE HUNTER
IT'S PATIENT THEREFORE WE FEEL
BILLS PREMATURE.
AS FAR AS RODNEY GOES.
WE ESTIMATE DECLINE OF REVENUE
OF APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND ANNUALLY AND COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THOUSAND.
THINK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
BUT ADDRESS THAT NOW.
ALL NOTE THAT.
WHERE THE IT DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I?
COMMITTED ON THE FISCAL ISSUES
TO. HELP GET THIS BILL OUT I
WILL NOT BE VOTING ON IT TODAY
ON A ON A POLICY MATTER BUT OUT
AND. I HOPE IT GETS OUT ON THE
FISCAL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THINKING.
SO THAT'S A DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS IT GETS OUT ON IT A
ROLL CALL.
WITH A.
MISS RESTS IN IN THE CHAIRED NOT
VOTING INVESTOR AND NAZARIAN
VOTING NO.
YOU BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU HAVE CHAIR MEMBERS
THINK IT.
WE.
NOW SECRETARY WILL YOU READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE NINETEEN FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE THREE
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SIX
TWENTY BY THIRTY FIVE. TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
ONE TWENTY FIVE SIX TWENTY SIX
SIXTY TWENTY SEVEN OH FIVE.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY TWO AND
THIRTY SEVENTY.
TO EMOTIONAL CONTENT COUNT MOVE
CONCERT. I HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
OTHER GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AN I UNDERSTAND.
THAT WE HAVE ONE PRESENTATION
ON THE SUSPENSE PHONE MISTER
CHOI YOU WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
ON YOUR SUSPEND ITS CANDIDATE IS
THAT. CORRECT.
MISTER CHOI.
MR SOIL BE PRESENTING ON AB
EIGHTEEN NO THREE ITS CANDIDATE
FOR SUSPENSE.
THANK YOU THE MORNING A LOT
MADAM CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THERE
MIGHT BE A LA I ATE I AB
EIGHTEEN OR THREE.
AB EIGHTEEN OR THREE OUT WHAT
THE REQUIRE A UNIVERSITY IS.
A WHO OR FOR BACCALAUREATE
DEGREES. OUT TO PROVIDE THAT
ACCESS UNTIL CARILLO SERVICES UP
TO FIVE YEARS SOUGHT AFTER DO
STUDENTS SO GRADUATE OF FROM DO
INSTITUTIONS.
ALL OF THE THIRTY TWO CS YOU AND
I UC CAMPUSES OF THE SERVER.
OUR UNDERGRADUATES ALL ONE NEED
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES ALL FOR
THOSE SO SERVICES TO RECENT
ALUMNI AT NO COST.
HOWEVER AT THAT PERIOD OF OUR
ELIGIBILITY ALL ARE OFTEN AND SO
WITHIN THE SIX MONTHS.
AFTER WHICH A STUDENT IS STILL
REQUIRED TO PAY ON AVERAGE
CHARGE OVER A FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A
YEAR. OUT TO ACCESS THAT THE
SCENE SERVICES AVE ALREADY PAID
THUS JORDAN THE SO WHO TEND TO
UTILIZE THE SERVICES THAT THE
MOST ARE OP UP BLACKS AND
HISPANICS STUDENTS.
AS WELL AS A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE AND DOT
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS SO OF
WHO ARE LEAST LIKELY AFFORD TO
PAY THESE FEES.
COLLEAGUES SAW BY ENACTING A BE
A TUNNEL THREE.
BUT THE SMALL AND OR SOLD OVER
ACOSTA WE PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HELP MORE RECENT.
GRADUATES
THE TEAM EMPLOYMENT. AND. TO THE
SOCIETY.
I RESPECT MEDIA ASK WE'LL BIBLE
EIFFEL.
DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
IF I NEVER.
BECAUSE SEE IF YOU ESTIMATES
COSTS OF THREE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS I'M GOING AND THREE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME. FINANCE
ESTIMATES COSTS FOR YOU SEE OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING.
AND.
COST PRESSURES OF ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHOI
THAT'LL BE MOVED TO SUSPENSE
FILE.
THERE MAY REPLY TO THAT.
YOU CAN.
A I DON'T KNOW WE THAT I FIGURE
COMES OUT MY COMMONSENSE OUT
BECAUSE TO ME. WELL
THE MOST OF THE UNIVERSITY'S OUT
DOOR FOR PLACEMENT SERVICES ARE
AND THE DISORDER BE*.
EXTENDING THE STUDENTS HOW MANY
ACTUALLY STOOD ON SO WHERE
UTILIZED AT THE SERVICES THAT IS
SO UNDETERMINED. AND THAT ALSO
IS NOT GONNA REQUIRE SUDDEN ARE
IN A FLOOD OF. OUR ALUMNI COMING
BACK UP TO USE OUT THE SOVIETS
WERE IT WOULD BE OUR ONLY ONE
GOING SO EXISTING OPERATION.
CANNOT PROVIDE THAT SERVICE ON
THIS ONE CREATE THE.
ARE ONLY GOOD THE RELATIONSHIP
AND THAT WHEN THEY. ARE
GAINFULLY IT REALLY.
EMPLOYEE. MOST LIKELY THE SAW
ALUMNI CAN CONTRIBUTED THE ARE
ALL OF TWENTY THIRTY ONE. TWENTY
SIXTY
FOUR TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE. TWENTY TO FORTY FOUR
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
TWELVE TWENTY SIX OH ONE AND
TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU IF ANYBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL THAT WAS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE THE AUTHOR WAY
PRESENTATION AT THIS MOMENT YOU
CAN COME UP AND YOU HAVE.
EIGHT EIGHT MAXIMUM OF TWO
MINUTES.
MADAM CHAIR TONY TO BEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ONE
APOLOGIZE TO THE AUTHOR TO THE
COMMITTEE WE JUST TOOK IT OPPOSE
POSITION. ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER'S TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN
REGARDING TO US SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER SO WE WILL BE GETTING A
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE ASAP.
THANK YOUNG THAT'S ON THE
SUSPENSE POWER.
I INCOME LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
SIXTY SEVEN US ARMS SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER IN EVERY SCHOOL
IS NOT THE SOLUTION TO KEEPING
KIDS SAFE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS THIS
MEANS ADJOURNED